you know what a compound bow is what
kind of archer are you mike
not a very good one i remember going to
a day camp when i was nine years old and
they had archery and i made the mistake
of
pointing the bow straight up in the air
and firing it as far as i could and i
got in trouble for that
because the higher it goes the farther
it goes and it potentially impales
someone on the way down so that wasn't a
good day for me
so i've avoided bows and arrows since
then but the compound bow is that big
ass bow that looks like it has
the fender of a buick on the front end
of it that's a compound bow
yeah mike clearly not born and raised in
the heart of new york city
no are far far familiar
with this type of stuff than i am mike
we were talking with howard beck earlier
about the idea of
nba journalists competing on survivor
how do you think nfl journalists would
do not former players
well that would be interesting i haven't
watched survivor in so long i can't
remember much about it other than
they're walking around basically naked
and eating bugs
so i don't know that i'd be interested
in that i know from time to time the
question comes up about like
fights and royal rumbles and mma matches
and obviously jay glazer would win
anything like that but
uh yeah it would be it would be
interesting i i'd rather observe it than
be part of it but it would definitely be
interesting no i wonder how long peter
king could live off the land well mike
what we have is here
that's a good question that's a very
good question
let's uh instead of talking uh
hypothermia and how you build a fort
let's talk a little about nfl football
shall we
uh what is happening uh in the nfc
east tj's already crowning the cowboys
as champions
the philadelphia eagles are losing on
their draft picks because carson wentz's
foot is broken
rich is predicting washington going to
the super bowl and saquon barclay's
coming back what is happening in the nfc
east
well we don't know when saquon barkley's
coming back which is concerning because
he tours aco in week two not in january
and we're conditioned to believe and
expect as we hear all the time
surgery is a success player is already
ahead of scheduling his rehab
everything's fine
until he's not fine so i'm worried about
barclay as are the giants i assume
washington is the team i like in that
division they may be the betting
favorites now they weren't the betting
favorites for most of the off season
but they have a very very strong nucleus
of young talent they've enhanced that at
quarterback with ryan fitzpatrick
assuming
he can bore be more fits magic and less
fits
tragic because we've seen in the past
once we buy into fitzpatrick that's when
he betrays all of us
and we start to think he stinks and then
he comes back and he plays well and it
just goes back and forth
but i think i have enough talent to win
that division again and i think they
have the kind of defense
that as it matures as it gets one more
season under its belt it could give tom
brady fits
if they cross paths in the playoffs and
i've been saying for several weeks now
that the washington football team is the
one team in the nfc
that the buccaneers don't want to
stumble across and route to
what now that aaron rodgers is back is
is likely a rematch of last year's nfc
championship
another team that i'm hoping is able to
compete with tb12 his cheekbones and
white jeans down in tampa at the los
angeles rams
bad news obviously with cam akers going
down but the addition of stafford brings
a lot of excitement to los angeles
what can we expect from sean mcvay and i
believe it's year five now for mcvay
i just wonder how much of stafford's
excitement
comes from the fact that it's stafford
or from the fact that they found a way
to unload jared goff
because it was obvious by the end of the
season
they wanted to get rid of golf they had
their hands tied by the contract that
they gave golf in june of 2019 a
contract they
never should have given and i'll say
that now because i said it then as they
were getting ready to do it
don't do it don't give them the money
they did and they ended up talking an
extra first round pick i believe into
the trade package
to get stafford in order to get rid of
golf and it's less conspicuous when you
do that
as part of a broader package than if you
would do like the texas did a few years
ago when they sent a second round pick
to the browns to take the brock osweiler
contract off their hands so
the ba the bar is high and they're
welcoming the hype and i'm i'm always a
fan of
managing expectations reducing
expectations
and already cam acres gone that changes
the offense dramatically
we'll see what stafford can do with that
offense we'll see this is a great
test case between the rams and the lions
will find out
a lot this year about whether or not the
struggles of the lions
since 2009 or about the lions
were they about matthew stafford can you
take him out of a bad organization
drop him into an organization that's
been good in recent years and all of a
sudden he's a different guy than he's
been his whole career it's gonna be fun
to watch mike florio joins the show
peacocks pro football talk do you think
mina times would be trustworthy
to build an alliance with on survivor
for an nfl journalist
i don't think anybody's trustworthy
alliance i remember enough about
survivor that ultimately you can't trust
anyone
trust no one one man alliance dwight
schrute
you trust to uh down in miami if you're
a dolphins fan this morning
i think you have no choice but to give
him a chance the problem last year is
the other two quarterbacks taken in the
top
six along with two uh performed
extremely well
and dolphins fans immediately get
very salty when you point out that the
dolphins took
to uh when justin herbert was still on
the board and he ended up being the
offensive rookie of the year so
it it it makes to his 2020 season seem
like a failure in comparison
and then there's the fact that he got
benched on multiple occasions and then
there's the fact that he admitted
earlier this offseason he didn't know
the offense well enough
which explains why they would pull him
in crunch time of a close game because
fitzpatrick did but
why didn't know the offense better why
wasn't he comfortable with
the audibles in the adjustments and
everything else that he needed to do so
that the pressure is on him in the team
this year
the dolphins generally are trending in
the right direction i still completely
roll out of the sean watson trade
although i think it's highly unlikely at
this point
but i think they'll give to this year
and and if he doesn't make a big jump
this year i think they're back in the
market next year for a quarterback
mike this is uh something i never
thought i would say in my
entire life but i'm gonna say it the
depth at quarterback for the bears
fascinates me
buried at the bottom of the depth chart
and now maybe they can unload him onto
the colts for a draft pick yeah it
really is amazing
they just need one of those guys to come
in and play at a high level which they
haven't had
since jay cutler arguably sid luckman
possibly
great sid luckman reference on the show
did not see that in the rundown heading
into
monday here on rich eisen ben lyons
joined by mike florio right now
and you mentioned nick foles is that the
best course of action you think for the
cults as they try to
rectify this disaster now at the
quarterback position for them i think
it'll be the cheapest in the simplest
way out of this the problem is
this range of potential return from
carson wentz
five to 12 weeks what if we had a spread
that big five to 12 we have what the
hell
what has to happen for it to be five and
what has to go wrong for it to be twelve
but they like jacob easton they've been
articles throughout the offseason about
how much they like
of course that's kinda how the game goes
you wanna pump up your young guys that
you hope becomes something in the future
falls makes a ton of sense i don't know
how wence would feel about
reuniting with foals but i think frank
wright could make it work if he had to
and
foles coming in there and full said
today he's heard the trade chatter he
doesn't want to go anywhere where he
doesn't know anyone and
i think indianapolis is where he would
most want to go
if that's how it were to play out and
there are a lot of options at this point
now jimmy garoppolo is floating around
out there and i don't think the colts
would pay him 25 million
but if there was some sort of a deal
that would involve a trade
and a reduction in this contract that
could be a possibility but if they would
make that kind of move
that would tell me it's 12 weeks or more
that carson wentz is going to be out
mike over the weekend i saw on instagram
that odell beckham jr bought 1.8 million
dollars worth of diamonds for his teeth
what's the most amount of money you've
ever spent on something to look more
handsome and also what's his role going
to be
in cleveland moving forward haven't seen
too much of obj
on the field with baker mayfield i have
spent
nothing i it's it's a hopeless case
right i don't there's nothing i can do
i don't even have a watch right now i
have an apple watch somewhere around
here i lost track of so
i'm very minimalist in that regard as it
relates to obj i think that would be his
best approach
assimilate into the offense don't be a
focal point
stop being the guy who constantly talks
about how much he wants the football
i think that was a major distraction for
the offense in 2019
when they were trying to settle into a
groove in baker mayfield's career and
anytime you've got that one guy who is a
receiver
who is crowing constantly about getting
the ball and it's an issue that's
discussed in
press conferences and there's this
genuine belief by the receiver that the
more i get the ball the more likely we
are to win i think that makes it so much
harder for the quarterback because
he stares down that receiver a little
bit longer waiting for him to get open
maybe he throws it into coverage
if he isn't the open man the best
offense is the one where you just go
through your reits one two three four
and maybe five if it goes that deep
and you just throw to the guy who's open
and you don't worry about who's getting
the ball
how many times he's getting the ball you
just throw to the open guy and that's
going to be the key this year for
beckham
don't talk about how often you're
getting the ball just be one of the guys
if you're open
and your numbers up in the progression
then you're gonna get the football
mike that is such a challenging ask of
odell beckham jr hey odell can you just
blend in and be one of the guys he just
spent two million dollars on diamonds
for his teeth how's he gonna be one of
the guys well
and here's the balance and i think we
saw some of this last year
remember we had that big game against
the cowboys not long before the torn acl
where he was doing it all he was running
the ball he was make
making the catches run after the catch
there are ways you can construct an
offense
to get the ball in his hands without
relying upon him
to be open because what defenses will do
if they know you're going to force the
ball to odell beckham jr early to get
him into the game and to get the offense
off on the right track they're going to
blanket him
so he can't get the ball but you use
screen passes you use
reverses you put in the back field there
are ways to get in the ball where he
doesn't have to get open where he can be
part of the offense and he can feel like
he's part of things
they just really need to avoid a
situation where there's
extra pressure on mayfield to get the
ball to beckham
on plays when getting the ball to
beckham isn't the right move to make
mike florio joins us right now from pro
football talk so
obviously he talks a lot about football
but what is the one story the one player
the one team that
us as football fans are just not talking
enough about you think here in august
well i can't say aaron rodgers although
we really have stopped talking about
that over the course of the last week
ever since he showed up i think we need
to be paying
a close amount of attention to
pittsburgh and what's going to go on
there this year i've said for
months now that i think both the
steelers and ben roethlisberger are
going to regret this one more year
and i think there was a lot of optimism
that got maybe a little unrestrained in
the building between
their playoff loss to the browns and the
moment they worked out a deal to bring
back roethlisberger for one more year
i just think they weren't happy with
their other alternatives and they didn't
see a path to getting a competent
replacement
and and and i really do think with him
now 39 years old
and showing signs of breaking down he's
had issues with his knees he had the
elbow thing a couple of years ago
their offensive line has had so much
turnover there's a chance
and and and i i regard mike tomlin as
one of the best coaches in the nfl and
he can maybe find a way to make chicken
salad out of this
but i think there's a chance it just all
falls apart for the steelers this year
and when we get to thanksgiving
both the team and roethlisberger are
going to be saying at least privately
why did we do this
and and i think it puts them in play for
aaron rodgers next year potentially
once we fire up that engine again in the
off season got brockman all excited over
there
you know a lot of different facial
movements no i i i i i i
no also just with ben mike i think this
season's going to be a disaster for them
i mean they didn't address really any of
their offensive line needs especially in
the draft like
what where what are they going to do
well and to have so many guys gone that
whole david de castro thing that kind of
dropped out of the blue that he's got
chronic ankle problems and they cut him
and that was the one guy they were
counting on coming back right you've got
all hundred villanova gone you've got
to castro gone marquis pouncey retired
kevin feiler signed with the charges as
a free agent i mean four out of five
starters on the offensive line are gone
and big cat and i got into this argument
on pft live a few weeks back where he
said well they weren't very good so
so they won't miss them but that's a
hell of a stretch because the guys who
were starters were the best they had
and now they're going to start jamming
in other guys and hope it works and uh
it's it's
it's a leap of faith that may not be
justified
mike appreciate you checking in taking
some time thank you as always
all right take care i'm going to go out
and buy a buy a bow and arrow and
yeah i'd love to see mike mike have to
hunt for his own
food yeah it'd be amazing i'm telling
you guys we're onto something with this
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here